[Music]
all organisms add new individuals to the
population by the process of
reproduction and this can be done by
either of the two methods that is
asexual or sexual mode asexual
reproduction is the preferred style of
lower organisms and is performed by
mitosis and how to sexually reproducing
organisms increase their population
that's a right answer sexual
reproduction is aided by meiosis we've
seen the process of meiosis in detail in
the previous videos let's summarize the
entire process in this video let's begin
with the preparatory phase that is the
interface first this cell goes through
three phases namely g1 phase S phase and
g2 phase in order to grow and prepare
itself for the actual division and can
you tell me what happens to the genetic
material during the interphase that's
correct the DNA is replicated to make an
identical copy of each chromosome on
similar lines other organelles of the
cell also get duplicated in this
complete phase among all the organelles
the duplication of one organelle is
equally important as the replication of
DNA and which organelle are we talking
about
yes it's the centrosome and why is the
duplication of centrosome so important
because this organelle contains
centrioles which formed the spindle
fibers needed for separating sister
chromatids later now
this perfectly grown cell is all set to
divide and entered the mitotic phase
according to the order the cell will
undergo karyokinesis and that would be
followed by cytokinesis let's dive
deeper into this world of meiosis
meiosis is carried out in two rounds
called meiosis one and meiosis two why
is that so that's correct
to obtain four haploid cells with half
the number of
resorbs compared to the parent cell
let's begin with meiosis one first
meiosis one is divided into four stages
they are prophase 1 metaphase 1 anaphase
1 and telophase 1 we will list down the
changes observed in the cell during
these stages step-by-step let's begin
with prophase 1 it's the longest phase
of meiosis 1 the phase is further
divided into 5 sub stages they are left
to teen zygote een packet een diplo teen
and diachrony says LEM protein is the
first sub stage in this phase the cell
begins condensation of the chromatin
making it short and compact the next
stage after lap 13 is the zygote in sub
stage here the homologous chromosomes
form a pair called the synapses the new
structure that is formed after the union
of two homologous chromosomes is called
a tetrad or a bivalent after forming by
valence the cell enters the next sub
stage called the packet een here the
bivalent exchange gene segments between
the non sister chromatids of homologous
chromosomes and can you tell me what
this process is called
that's the right answer it's called
crossing over and the location where the
exchange takes place is called chiasma
after successfully interchanging the
genes with one another the cell enters
the next sub stage called the diplo team
in diplo team the bivalent unbuttoned
themselves resulting in the separation
of the two homologous chromosomes but
here the tricky part is that the
homologous chromosomes are still
anchored at the chiasma finally in the
last sub stage called the diachrony says
the homologues get completely unhooked
and regained the individual identity the
nuclear membrane and the nucleolus
completely disappeared by the end of
prophase one
now let's move ahead with the next stage
of meiosis one that is metaphase one the
homolog pairs align on the equator of
the cell with random orientation this
arrangement is called the metaphase
plate and is a result of independent
assortment in the successive phase that
is the anaphase one the homolog pairs
separate from each other and move
towards the opposite poles finally the
cell undergoes the last phase that is
the telophase one along with the first
cytokinesis the two new cells obtained
are now haploid in nature the telophase
one followed by cytokinesis health's in
the formation of a nuclear membrane
surrounding the chromosomes and a
nucleolus as well the daughter cells are
haploid which are formed from the
diploid parent cells chromosomes however
are still seen attached to the sister
chromatids so in order to separate the
sister chromatids from each other each
haploid cell undergoes another round of
division but before moving ahead the
haploid cells enter a small resting
phase called the inter kinases it's a
short face with no activities involved
after going through this phase the cell
is all set to one to go the second round
of mitotic division the next round is
called the meiosis 2 it also includes
four stages in other words meiosis two
can be considered as the mitosis of
haploid cells the first phase is the
prophase 2 here the nuclear membrane and
the nucleolus begin disappearing the
chromatin condenses to become short and
compact and gains a typical chromosome
structure in metaphase 2 the chromosomes
align at the equator and the spindle
fibers attach to the respective sister
chromatids in anaphase 2 the chromatids
separate from each other and move to
opposite poles due to the contraction of
spindle fibers finally in telophase 2
the chromosomes D condense
the nuclear membrane envelopes the
chromosomes and the nucleolus also
begins to reappear the chromatids form
the daughter chromosomes at both the
poles last but not the least cytokinesis
helps divide the cell into two since two
cells have simultaneously undergone
meiosis two we get four haploid cells at
the end the haploid cells are also
called gametes and are genetically
different from each other and why is
that so genetic difference mainly occurs
due to recombination between the
chromosomes which takes place during
meiosis one and with this we come to an
end with the concept of meiosis now
let's have a look at the major
differences between mitosis and meiosis
in the next video
[Music]
you